je me demande ce que je fais je dis
souvent que je travaille sur les
expressions faciales
alors ça c'est la version officielle
en réalité je travaille sur les sourires
et ça fait déjà huit ans que ça dure
vous entendez mon accent je suis
polonaise et je peux vous dire que
sourire c'est pas du tout notre truc en
pologne
quand j'avais 18 ans je voulais être
traductrice maman voulait que je fasse
les études des droits que je sois
docteur et bien me voilà docteur d'en
sourire
les sourires sont des expressions
faciales étonnante est extraordinaire
c'est déjà des expressions qu'on partage
avec beaucoup d'espèces donc les chiens
les singes les renards ont tous des
expressions faciales qui ressemblent à
des sourires humains et nous les humains
nous sommes carrément programmé pour
sourire on sourit déjà avant la
naissance
et puis peu de temps après la naissance
et puis partout dans le monde
le sourire ces expressions faciales la
plus fréquente et la plus universelle
même pour les grands méchants pour les
terroristes pour les tribus les plus
isolées le sourire c'est quelque chose
de positif
mais c'est un autre type de situation
qui m'a poussé à travailler sur les
sourires une chercheuse américaine qui
un jour reçoit un coup de fil d'un
journaliste russe alors il y pose
quelques questions sur sa recherche
car les psychologues et apprend qu'elle
est américaine ah mais vous êtes
américaine vous devez donc savoir que
tous les sourires aux états unis s'en
faut et qui sauverait en france et oui
cette réfection du journaliste russe
c'est juste un exemple des malentendus
liés au sourire le sourire ces
expressions faciales et la plus
universelle
mais aussi celle qui peut être la plus
mal interprétés j'ai pensé à toutes les
choses qu'on peut exprimer avec un
sourire la joie la satisfaction
l'amour mais aussi la tristesse
lombard à la pitié et puis bien sûr on
sourit aussi pour cacher nos émotions
comme dans une ancienne opérette qui lie
toujours sourire le coeur d'un heureux
pour la personne qui voit un sourire
c'est donc pas toujours évident de
comprendre le message
et ça se complique encore plus quand on
rencontre des étrangers car en fonction
des pays et des cultures différentes
les sourires vont changer elle ne va pas
transmettre le même message est ce qui
m'intéresse moi c'est comment on sourit
aux inconnus dans des différentes
cultures
imaginez que vous achetez vos tickets de
bus ou de métro
allez vous sourira la personne à
l'accueil et un évidement ça dépend de
la personne
vous allez probablement sourire plus à
quelqu'un qui vous semble sympathique et
attirant gtalk à quelqu'un de
désagréable mais ça dépend aussi du pays
alors si vous êtes par exemple à londres
et que vous soyez au vendeur vous
donnerait probablement l'impression
d'être quelqu'un de poli et bien élevé
et bien ce sera pas pareil
si vous êtes à varsovie ou à moscow
là-bas votre sourire peut carrément
mettre les gens mal à l'aise
il ya même des expressions pour ça on
peut donner envie par exemple sourire
comme un conte à son fromage
alors je peux pas vous dire d'où vient
des fromages dans tout ça me voyez bien
c'est pas flatteur en russie c'est
encore plus clair il n'y a que des
idiots qui sourit sans raison j'ai une
amie française qui a vécu à moscou et
qui a pu constater que ce n'est pas
qu'une expression comme en russie il est
plutôt mal vu le sourire à des personnes
dans la rue et que mon ami avait que
quatre ans est bien là perdu l'habitude
de soria des personnes qu'elle
connaissait pas eh oui d'abord on sourit
pas de peur de se faire prendre pour un
idiot
pourtant les russes vont sourire
beaucoup quand ils sont en famille en
petit comité
là ils vont sourire parce qu'ils sont
bien entourés parce qu'ils sont heureux
si maintenant on compare ça avec les
pays comme le royaume uni ou les états
unis pour un anglo-saxon il est plus
normal de sourire à des personnes qu'on
viennent de rencontrer le sourire ne
veut pas nécessairement dire qu'en ce
sens heureux c'est plutôt je ne te
ferait pas de mal je veux que ça se
passe bien entre nous
donc s'il ya des malentendus par rapport
au sourire c'est parce que dans des pays
différents
on sourit différemment quelle est la
cause de ces différences c'est une
question plutôt difficile parce que les
sourires sont influencés par beaucoup de
facteurs donc par exemple en france le
sourire a été encouragé pendant le
siècle des lumières
et puis dans les pays communistes il
était plutôt mal vu de sourire si
quelqu'un souriez trop il devenait
automatiquement suspects déjà la vie
n'était pas une partie de plaisir donc
si quelqu'un souris c'est à dire que
soit ya d'argent soit ilan halimi du
système et puis au japon par exemple la
culture encourage à sourire pour cacher
ses émotions
nous nous sommes demandés s'il ya quand
même une tendance un peu plus général
qui permettraient d'expliquer pourquoi
dans certains pays les gens vont sourire
plus aux inconnus nous pensons que ça a
influencé par l'histoire
je vous explique certains pays ont été
créés d'un mélange de personnes des
différents pays et de différentes
cultures en australie par exemple il n'y
a que 2 % de la population actuelle qui
descendent de leurs ancêtres qui ont
vécu sur place
en 1500 tous ces immigrés qui ne se
connaissaient pas n'avaient pas de base
commune pour se comprendre
il avait donc vraiment besoin d'utiliser
leurs visages et de sourires pour
signaler leurs bonnes intentions aux
autres historiquement il fallait que les
australiens souris pour établir des
connexions sociales
si maintenant on prend la pologne un
pays que je connais bien il n'y a pas eu
beaucoup d'immigration depuis 500 ans
les gens qui vivent là-bas descendent
principalement de la population qui a
vécu sur le même territoire depuis des
siècles comme leurs ancêtres pouvait
communiquer clairement leurs intentions
grâce à une langue commune ils avaient
moins besoin de montrer ouvertement
leurs émotions
nous pensons que cette immigration
historique
ces déménagements culturelle par
le passé ont pu influencer la manière
dont sourit aujourd'hui pour aller plus
loin sur ces déménagements culturel j'ai
besoin de vous parler des deux
chercheurs de l'université de brown aux
états unis il ya quelques années
louis spiderman et invite doyon ont
déterminé pour chaque pays du monde
le nombre de pays source par exemple les
états unis en 83 pays source
c'est des records vous pouvez voir sur
la carte plus c'est clair
plus il ya de pays source ça veut dire
qu'aux états unis les immigrants de 83
pays différents ont contribué à la
population américaine
entre 1500 et 2000 en général le
continent américain
on a plus que l'europe et le japon et à
l'autre extrême avec un seul pays source
l'allemagne en a par exemple 7 et puis
les pays bas 28 ce qui fait pas mal pour
l'europe
si je vous dis que la pologne à trois
pays source
combien on a la france d'après vous
es-tu fort peut-être 10 bat vous n'êtes
pas loin on est à onze donc pas si mixte
que ça
plus un pays à deux pays sources plus il
a été mixte dans le passé alors avec ce
nombre de pays source
nous avons une mesure de ses
déménagements culturelle par le passé
alors comment on fait pour lier ça au
sourire
eh bien il faut commencer par
l'expression d'émotions en général
imaginez que vous êtes dans un café avec
votre père et que vous êtes fâché contre
lui
pensez vous qu'il faille montrer la
colère la montrait un tout petit peu
n'ont rien montré du tout peut-être
juste se taire sourire en souffrent nous
avons posé cette question à plus de 5000
personnes dans 32 pays différents et
nous avons observé que dans des pays
plus mixte avec plus de pays source
les gens pensent qu'ils devraient
exprimer leur colère
plus que des gens
pays peu mixte qui en moins de pays
source en gros ça veut dire que les
russes avec leurs cinq pays sources sont
moins expressif que les américains nous
avons posé cette question pour
différentes personnes est différent de
situation donc le père c'est juste un
exemple
et chaque fois on arrive à la même
conclusion dans des pays plus mixtes les
gens pensent qu'il est plus approprié
d'exprimer ouvertement leurs émotions
mais revenons précisément au sourire et
à des raisons qui nous poussent à
sourire dans la même recherche
nous avons demandé aux personnes dans 9
pays différents y compris la france le
japon les états unis l'australie et
israël
qu'est ce qui constitue une bonne raison
pour sourire dans leur pays c'est pas
une grande surprise par tous les gens
pensent qu'on sourit parce qu'on se sent
heureux
alors là ça va tout le monde est
d'accord mais dans des pays plus mixte
qui en plus de pays sources comme par
exemple australie où les états unis les
gens pensent qu'on sourit aussi pour
être agréable et cette tendance un peu
moins forte dans les pays qui ont peu de
pays sources comme par exemple le japon
si la prochaine fois un fonctionnaire
américain vos souris ça veut pas
forcément dire qu'il s'agit d'un souris
faut ça veut pas dire non plus que les
fonctionnaires est hyper joyeux c'est
juste qu'il veut être agréable et qui a
grandi dans une culture historiquement
mixte qui a encouragé ce type de sourire
envers les inconnus
notre manière de sourire est influencé
par notre pays par ces déménagements
culturel l'immigration dans le passé qui
a formé la culture de notre pays
mais alors équipe possible d'influencer
notre manière de sourire aujourd'hui oui
je vous rassure notre recherche montre
que la fréquence de déménagement a un
effet très similaire à celui du nombre
des pays sources
c'est à dire plus les gens déménagent
dans un pays donné
plus ils sont expressifs et plus il
sourit c'est à dire que déménager et
probablement aussi voyager veut nous
pousser à sourire pour établir un
rapport de confiance avec des gens que
nous ne connaissons pas est ce que ça
veut dire que les gens dans les pays peu
mixte comme par exemple la france ou la
pologne sont peu accueillants et qui
devrait apprendre à sourire plus souvent
surtout pas ce serait trop simple
le message que j'aimerais vous laisser
aujourd'hui c'est que les sourires sont
un peu comblé longue
il n'y a pas de langue meilleurs que
d'autres et puis ça peut être difficile
de comprendre une langue étrangère sans
préparation surtout pas penser à ça la
prochaine fois quand vous voyez un
sourire ou un manque de sourire qui vous
semble faux c'est à vous de choisir de
penser que ce sourire est faux ou de
faire un effort pour mieux comprendre
merci